>>> BREAKING NEWS.
SSWOMAN LIZ CHAINY IS
TAKIIRM  FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUM NEW
OP-ED PUHED MOMENT WCN H HON AN
LE INTO THAT GOO
T ALL.
THIS IS, I AM IN
EANGNOW.T SHE CONSIDER LONG WAR
THE T IS THEOPS ATA TURNING T.CH
IT STAR
DD THCT
HE IS CTIG TOTO
QUOD R UST TOU A SENSE OF IT
E VIOLENCETRUMP ISEE TO L ALS O.
IDENCE ITH
EC OF LAW. OTHERCAN PRESID
EV DD THEN,
SH ON.SHDO
REPUBLICAN LEADER KEVIN
SHE CALLS HIM OUT FOR CHANGING
HISTY ONth.
E
AND TH TVE RRTCE OF E RULE OF LA
TH OA
REPUBLICAN VERSUS THE PARTY OF
SHE SAYS, QUOTE REPUBLICAN
CONSERVATIVERISTR E DANGEROU
ANANTI-DEMOCRATIC TRUMOF PERSONY
ON TO LY
REPUBLICANS TO US THE TISAYS
TURNING POIN HISTORY
ATM
ATTRACTIVE AND TRUMP
ISGEROUS TT READ HERE,
PAH WHICTHUP.
SHE SAQUOTE,
G.WE MUS BRAVE ENOUGH TO
NC
E SHORRM PROTECT OD OUR  P.TTEDT
NCES
>> KIND AL
AGNSE McCARTHY BACK IN N OF CIE
G THIS "THE WASHIN P
E CONSERVATIVE RIGHTCONSIDER TO?
SHE DO ITH I DON'T KNOWH
"THE WASHINGTON POST
THEERGT>>Y. POLITIC WIL
STARTING, LAUNCHING G TO BE THEA
Y BELIEVESNGER TO THIS ANDTHAT
FIND ITSELAGAIN, ANDG TO SEE TH
THATPALL SEE HAS ANY
BRINGIHANGEL, THANKS SO MUCH F
>> ALSO IN THE POLITICS LEADOS
FROM RUDY  HOM
OFFICE AS AN ATTEMPT TO HEAD
ANNI DEFENSE COMPLAIS T THE RA P
VIOLATIONS OF ATTO
PRIVILEGE.
CLIENTS, OF
GIULIANI BEING INVESTIGATED FOR
HIS DEALINGS IE WHETHER HE DID
AN OFFICIA
CNN'S EVAN PEREZ JOINS
HAS GIULNI RESPONDED TO THIS
REQUEST FOR AN
EW
AR JAKE, FROM HILEGAL TEAM THEYI
HE WANTSMAAT
MATERIAL IS IN HANF
INVESTIGATORS THAT THEY DON'T
DEE, SO WHAT EXPECTING
THAT WILNTIS THIRD-PARTY JUDGE
A LOOKE
DEVICES TAKEFR ASSISTANT AND TH
COURSE, THERE IS THE DICHE
CELL PHONECTORIA TOENSING
ANHEO
DAY, AND AT OF THESE
LAWYERS ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
CASE THAT THERE'S STUFF THAT THE
GOVENTE
HAVE NO RIGHT
TO SEE, SO YOU CAN PROBL
EXPECT IT'S GOING TOA THS  LS T
>> GIULIANI'S ADVISE REMEMBERS G
GAL FEES.
T MUCH IS CLEAR IST
RUDY HAS MONEY PROBLEMS, JAKE,
AND BOTH HIS -- HIS N ANDREW
GIULIANIKE
HERE AT CNN AND WHAT THEY ARE
SAYINGUSE WHATULIANI WAS DOING
WAS ON BEHALHESIDENT.
>> YEAH.
E IS PERTE
RESULT OF THAT, AND AS AT  DESS
D ESNT DE CAMPAI, ARE ASKING F
THE RN STEP IN OSOME OF EY KNOW
SLY PRESIDENT TRUM
RAISED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BECAUSE OF THEIGU
POST-EIOE OF
THAT MON
GIULIANIUG COULD BUSELY FOR WHAO
ATTY HEFTL FEE FOR
GIULIANI.
SEEMS LUEST.
HE WAS DOINGHE BEHESION OF TRUM
MEMO WRITTEN BY BILL BARR ABOUAE
IN
ABOUT?
NT THIS IDEA RULING  JUDWHO ISE
THAT THEY CAN KEEPT THIS
MEMO FTHE OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL.
MBER, BARR WAS
CRITICIZED FOR HE CAME OUT
D THE FINDINGS OF
THE MUELLE
HE NTED
>> MISREPRESENTED THEM.
IN WASHIFI BILL CTLY JUDGEACKSON
BARR DISINGENUOUS AND SAYS
THO FAR FR ESSENTIAL
IN BARR WAS TRYING
TOE DECISIS TO N B CHARG AGAINS
IDFO
OBSTIO
SHE'S SAYING T NO, HE HAD
ALREADY MADE -S O THE HAT HE WAS
USING THIS -O TO HELP
MAKE HIS DECISION ISLSE.
>> MHEE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL.
SO SHETHAT IS HAT NEEDS TO BE
RELEASED.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE BIDEN
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL APPEAL
THIS OR IF THEY WILL JUST TURN
IT OVER, BUTT ALSO, I THINK,
KEGEHIS
MEMO, WE MAY GET TE A LITTLE
BIT MO
WAS MADE BECAUSE, YOKNOW  HAVE
EVAN, THANKSMUCH. MER U.S.
BHARARA. F THEERN RICT OF NERK
WH
WELL, IT'RYTED
W THIS
LITIGATION BEFORE THE COURTHE J
KEEP THOSE PORTIONS REDACTEDINK
SITTING FEDERASTRICT COURT
JUDGE HAS BASICALLSA
OR
UNITED STATES BILL BARR WA
E AS BEING
DISINGENUOUS AND WE HAVE OTHER
I 'S VERY IMPORTANT UK LAW ENFOT
OFFICEEDS AND ALSOT TOREFERRED
TO AS BEING
TA RATHER THAN LEGAL
L SE
WITH  HOW
D TO DIBD
CAMPAIGN TO JUSTIFY THINGS AE B
PROPER LEGAL ETHICAL
DETERMINATION.
THEFOREIGN MINISTER
OFAI TOLD MATTHEW CHANCE
THAT HE'S NOAWE EVER ANY
REQUESTS FROE TO HELP WITH THEIN
RUDY GIULIANI.
L FOR THE U.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OR TO
ASK THE GOVERNMENTF UKRAINE R A
INVESTIGATION GIVEN THATS
ON BEHAL UKRAINIANS.
>> KNOW, IT'NOT FOITED STATE
AUTHORITIES WHO DID IT ALL THE
K
SSE  THA
SENSITIVE.
IT MAY BE THE CASE THAT THE
AMIC THINK